president and the administration are
100% committed to getting Exim Bank
reauthorized it's an absolutely
fundamental tool that we need to help
American businesses sell their goods
around the world 60 other countries have
similar Exim banks we don't want to give
up a financing tool for whatever reason
I don't understand this is really really
important and there are American jobs on
the line and that's what seems crazy to
me there's clearly opportunity
electrification and president wants to
spend 7 billion but five of that billion
is from the X and makin their persuasive
arguments you just made mrs. secretary
but are those going to be persuasive on
Capitol Hill I think will be successful
in Capitol Hill because I think every
district in this country has a company
that's selling something around the
world that if it isn't their product
that's getting Exim financing they're
supplying to a product that's getting
Exim financing so I think that we'll get
there should the administration mr.
mayor have a plan B if XM funding
doesn't doesn't come through if the
reauthorization doesn't have it I think
that they have to focus right now on
getting it through if something doesn't
happen
look you can't a plan B for everything
in this case I think Penny's 100% right
when people stop and think about it this
is not a political thing
this is something that every other
country does if we're going to be
competitive we have to do it if you
think that we shouldn't do it and you
can get all of the countries to stop
then we'll have a level playing field we
won't have as much business because this
does is the catalyst and gives people
the ability to buy now and pay later but
nevertheless it's the competitive aspect
that I worry about when we talk about
growth we talk about opportunities for
your business infrastructure is one of
them do you see I mean the GES announced
another two billion today they sell high
tech trains big ticket items on
infrastructure on the sort of basics of
building roads and cities where are the
opportunities well I let a trade mission
to Ghana and to Nigeria just a few
months ago there's enormous opportunity
there are companies that are helping scw
from you know North Carolina there
the Ghana Electric Company get the most
out of their grid how do they make it a
smart grid how do they do more to get
electricity out of their infrastructure
there is so much opportunity in terms of
power electricity technology solar
there's and and what we know and what
does the president know why is he been
pushing power Africa you need power in
order for your economy to continue to
grow and an Africa is underpowered every
way you look at it I don't care how you
analyze it they need hundreds of
billions of dollars of infrastructure
particularly power and we're and your
list you'll hear the president will
announce not only deals but a greater
intention around power obviously power
important so our roads getting to and
from places when you look at cities mr.
mayor what cities are investing in the
right way and their infrastructure
you mentioned Nigeria leg was a pretty
tough town to get across if you want to
get from the center of town the airport
it can take a good day but look this
clearly not enough roads for a lot of
places in the world including some of
the cities unfortunately it's tough to
get around some American cities and
those things that impedes the ability to
get to a place for education or medical
care or commerce and that sort of thing
but I think one of the things you've got
to look at is technology is different
today you don't have to have the same
infrastructure that you used to have to
have today 50% of the people in Africa
have a smartphone they didn't go and run
telephone lines all over the cut of the
continent you don't do that in this day
and age this satellite communications
this cellular communication and the same
thing is true for the commerce there's
air today which it didn't have before if
I've been recently in South Africa in
Cape Town and Johannesburg thriving
bustling cities do they have poor people
who need help
absolutely so do we in our country and
we've got to take care of our poor poor
and they've got to take care of theirs
and sometimes we can even help each
other but they have this a spirit you
look on the streets and you say wait a
second these cities are going to be real
competitive well we talked about all
these trends come together urbanization
in Africa big cities potential for
finance
is Africa going when you look at finance
on investment vehicles are they going to
be the new issue what's the next Hong
Kong in Africa well it's gonna take a
while I think South Africa you know I
don't know where the generation is 20
years that goes pretty quickly but they
are there are stock exchanges all
through Africa they trade derivatives
there's all sorts of kinds of financing
that will let you have different risk
profiles and payment profiles cash flow
profiles the this day and age things are
happening much more rapidly than what
they did before I build on that so when
I when we were in Africa one of the
places we visited was meltwater were
there training young innovators and
entrepreneurs African innovators and
entrepreneurs how to take an idea and
make it into a business plan create an
entity get it financed and get out and
build a new business that's a key part
of the opportunity in Africa is help the
entrepreneurs begin to build their
businesses with the kind of
infrastructure that we're talking about
that becomes more and more possible it's
very exciting to see the innovation
that's going on in Africa and what's
really cool is you don't need any more
to have you know significant personal
infrastructure to be able to invent and
create let's say a new app a new game
new new products that the market takes
up on its cellphone so it's just amazing
what is going on there and I think it's
one of the reasons to be very excited
and one of and if there's an enormous
opportunity for American business